you devancé squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur the empty malghem vous
souvenez vous de géométrie dash moi je
préfère une part bons souvenirs on
n'était pas j'étais nul à chier sur ce
je vois là et là c'est à peu près le
même jeu mais sur pc c'est parti ah ah
ça y est encore histoire de niveau 1 2 3
4 on n'avait pas passé niveau indre je
maîtrise h mais bon c'est parti niveau 1
je voulais aussi en profiter pour vous
remercier parce qu'on est trois millions
d'abonnés à la chaîne youtube c'est
vraiment un chiffre de dingue je voulais
faire une vidéo pour vous remercier un
zapping de la bêtise numéro 2 mais j'ai
pas eu tort et créé par guillaume
turquie etc
voilà ça c'est dit ok c'est parti à
tanger au moins de son os tout temps
tout en mourant bien sûr et bat déjà sur
fait si chaud qu'on va être plus fort
vous allez voir je sens après je suis
pas sûr mais il ya moyen
voilà voilà donc plus jamais le mot là
dans cette vidéo on sache bien le dire
je me rase tout bon plus le moins
instantanément aussi dans cette vidéo en
fait j'aimerais bien qu'on pas juste le
niveau 1 dans celui là éventuellement
plus éventuellement butin perdre et je
finirai la vidéo sans parler quoi vous
parler à ma place je savais quoi allez
je vous donne le micro à les y parlait
bien vu j'ai retiré le micro et je suis
mort directe c'est vraiment laid ils
veulent vous dans ce jeu alors voilà ok
je me tais voilà je me fais bien moi je
vais complètement exclure cette vidéo
c'est scandaleux
je suis passé au practice mode en
faisant ça sur mon clavier
je veux jouer en mode normal il n'a pas
quand je chante non plus mais qu'est ce
qu'on ferait on joue avec les pieds
jabra fois jeu vidéo pieds nus donc je
me sens obligé de monter finalement
allez c'est parti avec le pied
merde [ __ ] bon gros doigts pile
appuyer sur une touche qui fout pas
c'est bon c'est un test
elles sont pas ce niveau c'est
incroyable on n'est pas trop mal hu
non mais regardez regardez ça je vous
explique la et des [ __ ] de touche la
barre espace et quand j'appuie là ça
passe au practice mode bordel
du coup on doit plus bas je me fâche
aussi et après on s'engueule avec mon
doigt de pied à cause de jeu bordel à
décoiffer au bout de deux minutes de
vidéo enfin exclu sévèrement coiffer on
s'en bat les steaks hockey est ce que je
vaux juge moi non nous sommes une team
nous baby boxe du pauvre putmeup top on
va y arriver ne perdons pas espoir vous
en faites pas je sens que bientôt c'est
le décès sauf aux heures de jeu c'est à
eux ces tirs je veux bien qu'on perd
contre eux mais des cubes c'est nos
poteaux on veut faire de lifesize dans
le cul môquet est franchement été
meilleure avec le doigt de pied le gros
doigts de pieds en plus pas l'utiliser
le gros quand même il pèse un peu
d'envié de jeux vidéo a à toi lui par
exemple pas du tout en plus je me donne
des défis alors que même son effigie
arrive pasqua dépens des bills ont déjà
mal aussi mais on n'est jamais aussi
loin à la fois sentez vous m'aurez pas
avec ce piège de merde banal dans we
don't worry non mais la laisse pas
pousser ok je sais j'ai appuyé sur la
touche espace extremis nickel non mais
tu fais quoi tu fais quoi
o a laissé les gages pendant ce temps
les mains allez on s'y attendait tous
voilà la main entre les jambes
ouais ça marche bien là oh oh ok ok tout
en toi conte qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce bonsoir je suis une mouche
l'illusion est parfaite je me produis
sur scène aussi en tant que
illusionniste à et en tant que nul à
chier au jeu vidéo [ __ ] mais encore au
niveau 1 mais je sais pas j'y arrive pas
j'arrive pas c'est danser dans les
veines c'est dans le coeur dans les
artères dans ouais c'est quoi c'est quoi
faire comme pour je m'étais d'âge nous
on n'a pas le temps on n'a pas le temps
commence t vos deux directs chaos
fantaisie en plus c'est bien plus
intéressant que tu me laisses parler on
est passionné passion n'est pas si on
est passé
ouais bah ça pas du allons tora au giro
lâche les eaux les voisins du dessous
voilà je t'envoie ce feutre tu attrapes
au sodium voisin est un poisson
voilà bien ok oui si vous bien ok oui
mais mais will do date
tuga la haye dont speak english very
well bottes et tout est bloqué
j'ai tendance à 1-1 hockey chemin au mix
nul floquet je suis pas sur ce jeu a
expliqué rich and because ayad to
practice mayenne glee show l'absorber
absolument parfait novethic et par mon
accent voilà par votre faute voilà donc
ceux qui ont critiqué une action déjà
bas je vous banni à vie de la chaîne et
si je ne peux pas mais qui ragent coupe
bon quoi le fait qu'ils regardent la
vidéo il est là il a rien fait
d'accepter zad et il se fait agresser
mais a certainement on va y arriver
je vous entends être pessimiste voilà
votre pc militer mais bon déjà la touche
espace de mon clavier pour le mediashare
apprécié j'ai si le type de cette vidéo
est écrit tout collé vous saurez
pourquoi mais évidemment c'est horrible
oh mais will never go longue aziz
pourquoi je parlais c'est honnête aux
caraïbes
[Musique]
cette musique mme anesthésie
celle là je vais chez le dentiste il n'y
a pas d'eau mais ce n'était pas exempt
vie mais ça met les oreilles ces partis
mais comment je fais moi même à quoi bon
mais on se détend en même temps c'est le
niveau 4 on l'a cherché
je m'en fous c'est un honneur pour moi
d'aller plus loin que la peau d'un bon
ok j'ai payé 5 euros par à ce jeu 5
euros pour ruiner ma barre et c'est le
cri silencieux ok 5 euros pour casser ma
barre espace pour devoir avoir un
clavier pour mme emilie pourquoi
pourquoi alors comment jouer voilà
explique moi appuyer sur le bouton qui
ça a sauté pour sauter merci merci
vraiment merci beaucoup et maintient le
bouton qui permet de sauter pour sauter
en boucle merci merci beaucoup saute par
dessus les piques et saute sur les blocs
pour arriver jusqu'à la fin du niveau
si tu te crache tu réapparaîtra au début
du niveau appuyez sur le bouton ajouter
un drapeau donc c'est lui là c'est lui
la chaux je transpire jeu pas mis des
eaux d'oran
después comme jambo
on a bien vu ça faisait un smiley
regarder attention ce valet vous avez vu
c'était intéressant vraiment aller on
passe sur les yeux de ce bail et on s'en
va et c'est qu'on n'a pas le temps au
plus vous rigolez mais j'ai eu mes
tisanes mukwege ai pas vu où vous l'avez
tous téléchargée 1
pourquoi j'ai pas vu et que vous m'avez
tous twitté vos [ __ ] de scor de pgm
et quoi j'étais imposition foetus
pendant une semaine et bill sur mon
siège ok si oui ou non franchement bien
jeu parce que honnêtement c'est l'un des
jeux où j'arrive le moins à jouer ta
j'avais des mecs qui m'ont envoyé des
screen sur twitter qui est passé au
niveau 4 et 5 et je me disais mais
comment faites vous êtes-vous iron man
oui oui ça c'est beau et ça c'est grâce
aux conseils qui nous ont donné
finalement appuyé sur espace pour sauter
je veux dire voilà ça nous a
complètement non faut pas sauter passer
en dessous chaplin a partout sur mon
clavier sur le practice mode quoi un
moment j'ai compris que j'étais mieux
que ça va on passe par-dessus peaks est
incroyable c'est pas comme si on avait
fait 800 mille fois avant à huy est pas
mal il ya un petit niveau il ya un petit
niveau c'est à l'odeur qu'on peut
mesurer le taux de rage études un jeu
finalement il faut lier ou comme ça dans
l'espace et non mais les mecs mais nous
on fait monter un étage mais ça c'est
plus un étage quoi était intraitable
j'ai moi même pas compris ce jeu de mots
c'est quelqu'un a compris qu'il
m'explique dans les commentaires
mon propre jeu de mot merci beaucoup ok
beatbox experts level 1 oui
ah oui est ce qu il m me voir ridicule
ce [ __ ] de jeu on va voir
or pour faire des aaa
j'ajoute un truc à chaque fois que je me
suis déjà plus rien badge points noirs
bien gratuit fin pas gratuit le scotch
comme un faucon se concentrent un nouvel
atout qu'on se concentre un peu quand on
fait des petits des petits jeux mignon
entre nous et tout mais ce qu'on s'aime
bien mais là un moment il faut quand
même qu'on se concentre ok je sais que
si je gagne vous êtes fier de moi en
plus ce serait tous fiers de moi malgré
tous victory nous avons tout défoncer ue
avec un accent anglais on se bat pour
quoi surtout que à l'écrit on verra pas
avec son anglais je crois en vous vous
croyez par mois avait avant l'escale et
de 600 mm je suis deg si on passe ce
niveau les gars ces accords et les
filles
oui ce serait à [ __ ] ça m'a troublé
n'oubliez pas quand on veut quelque
chose on peut la voir
jean il pleurait oui ok mais intéressé
j'ai perdu mon sang-froid et voilà j'ai
déjà fin de cdd sur rim possible game
baugé au deuxième étage version 4 de
28.2 personne n'a plus ces cas n'hésitez
pas à aimer la vidéo comme d'habitude on
se retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo avec je l'espère un peu moins de
rage sur les midis matinée me disent que
vous voulez dire tout le monde dit ça
[Musique]
m